welcome to this oops video playing pac
see i could have played c4 why not maybe
should do that more often to get more
variety in the openings so Peck see is
the corner from Finland we got a Ben Oni
going for Bishop a form that's like that
i think is quite quite good but i should
study it more already we know the
general outlines but not any a big
details big details that's wrong nem
sufficient detail so that's probably
better better way of phrasing it so how
is this plate is going for b5 maybe I
can still play some Norman King rules
Queenie 7 hmm
hmm so he's out for be five and maybe
Bishop c3m maybe this is really
something that he wants to do okay let's
protect this interesting not something I
expected very much thought a bee but ok
it's got 94 as a possible an option so i
think i'm going to take and now who k7
let's activate that rook
not sure I'm threatening me five here
maybe I am I think I might threaten this
after a possible bishop f1 coming
the move Queen have success is something
that somehow keeps coming to my mind
taking f4 and CM + b2 I don't want to
play Bishop see one but I'm not really
sure what else to do okay if it takes me
to I can take group you want to get be
five so probably I can just go back and
d6 hang so again not a problem at all so
this is an interesting move would be six
hmm before something that I would like
to play but I don't really see after
taking what my next move is maybe we
should be three actually but should be
three rook moves and Bishop t4 it's an
interesting interesting idea and let's
try that I didn't really didn't really
calculate it in much detail but it looks
interesting at least here I can take and
go Bishop g4 or Bishop b5 I don't know
Bishop g4 maybe trading that Bishop and
both both his pawns a week but he might
have some counter play against may you
fall upon he might have I'm not not
really not really sure about it
probably some rook c8 he needs he needs
the temple gain I guess now Roxy it
looks very normal does he have anything
else hmm take on the form that this
reply is easy yeah this one I thought
there should be five I guess we should
be five killing oh I didn't see that one
coming
yeah Bishop c6 sb3 as well ok let's play
it
I have to be tactically very alert and
the modern be no needs really am
strategically dubious opening but like
it's got many tactical chances as we
have seen here should be five I didn't
seem so do i somehow get this pawn this
is what I was was hoping for of course
something with five maybe on 94 here is
got 94 hmm and knight Knight takes e4
Falls whom
pretty awful maybe you 559 a for queen
bee three Queen if I broke a 100k 886 it
could be okay could be I know after play
moh cannot cannot wait forever he has
other moves over gay a door other Abby
to wear also be too that's probably
probably just good be too I it's not
exactly a difficult move to play huh
yeah I know night info I guess so
yeah just lost our bad game that game
hmm so that really didn't see that d5
was hanging time morning
what a shame only a little trickier that
I see something with 94 night beach well
then Queen c3 this is the only thing
that I seem nice he wants 97 no ma chief
or something I don't know it just lost
aiming for Queenie 5 check in case of
queen bee three or something but you can
go Queenie form and Queen give okay man
back
93 I can still take them mr. min
exchange down then no move that's crazy
but then I have no I have no time and no
position
I can take a 93 I have to check here
check white resides wow that was bad I
can't sell boobs let's see the clip
Tiger pretty normal position 7 this one
ok so now I got good said Ian and I
really felt that this should be good for
white but yeah the engine gives wide
very big advantage but I couldn't really
couldn't really make it work I here I've
got 27 that's not very difficult forces
forces the art form sorry forces a very
awkward move yes to go Bishop c8 back
and then I'm really just better ok I
couldn't really believe in that that
taking was right and this is what this
was the key move that I didn't didn't
think about my idea with B form was
always to to to trade his bishop this is
why I went Bishop deform but he has to
go back I mean you cannot go here
because this is good or this is good so
after Queen c70 really emphasis this is
not just better for what yeah very
obviously so I mean it's just passive at
the pawn this week you can't eat here
try for this thing
but you can also check here and here why
this just better my pieces are more
active and yeah like a suffering him so
this this was the mistake and I'd see
five year now the problem is after
Bishop beehive there is this the move
that happened and this is what I didn't
see I was thinking that he I'm better
because I get a piece to c6 and then i
can try to win the before pawn but he
just has this technical resource and it
makes the position it turns the position
from being bad being good well after I
didn't see we should be final thinking
okay this Bishop is terrible but after
this is not just winced the pawn but
also activates the bishop and now I'm
just losing yeah I continued a little
bit but i don't think i don't think
there was ever a particular opportunity
for me just trying to muddy the waters
yeah i could have taken f7 and draw
probably this is injustice is a draw
according to the engine yeah i get both
pawns but anyway that is really not
important I overlooked that Bishop takes
d5 thing so deservedly lost this game
thanks for watching